The reason for Mach's expensive border
crossing, is it's focused on portability. What
that means is that, the Mach
microkernel is architecture independent to allow that
Mach microkernel to run on several
different processor architectures. What that means is
that there's going to be a code bloat in the Mach microkernel because it has
to have the personality for any architecture that it may need to run on.
In particular, in the Mach microkernel, there
is an architecture independent part of the microkernel,
an architecture specific part of the microkernel.
The two together results in a significant code
bloat, which means it has a large
memory footprint. Which means, it has lesser locality.
Which means, you're going to have more cache
misses and pollution of the cache. And that
is the reason why you have a longer
latency for border crossing in Mach, as opposed
to the theoretically smallest number of processor cycles
in order to go from user space to
kernel space. As I mentioned earlier, LeKay did
back-of-the-envelop calculation on the same processor hardware and
said that it should take about 107 cycles
to go from user space to kernel space. And
then he implemented L3 microkernel and showed that it
took only 123 processor cycles to do that. And
the reason for Mach's expensive border crossing is
all due to the fact that there is code
bloat, resulting in more cache misses and therefore incurring
longer latency for border crossing. So in other words,
Mach kernel's memory footprint is the
culprit for the expensive border crossing. It
is not the philosophy, or the
principle, of microkernel based operating system design,
because by proof of construction, L3 has shown that you can have very
minimal border crossing overhead by careful construction.
Another way of saying it is that
portability, which was one of the main concerns in Mach design, and
performance, are at loggerheads with each other. So if you focus on portability,
you may sacrifice performance, and that's what we saw when we look at
the difference between Mach's performance and
L3's performance on the same processing hardware.